Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
Monday.
Um,
what is today?
It's January 19th.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm actually taping this on Sunday.
First
much in the Patriots right now.
The are up 14 to seven,
four minutes to go into fucking foot.
Second quarter.
Joe.
Joe,
what are you,
what are you supposed to be fucking Paul Murphy.
You fucking goddamn colonial hat.
Um,
alright.
I've gotta be honest with you guys.
I already recorded a podcast this week with a very special guest.
Uh,
but it's,
it's a famous drummer and a,
I think it's going to be too much of a drum head thing for a while.
You guys had just like,
are you still listening to me talk about sports?
So I'm going to do a quick one here Monday and then I'm going to have,
uh,
I have an interview with Chris Leighton from a Stevie Ray Vaughan and double
trouble back in the day from arch angels.
I saw him touring last year,
came through the Greek with Kenny Wayne Shepherd.
Um,
he does that Hendricks review thing and he's actually in town here in la working
with Stephen Stills.
So,
uh,
if you're into drums and uh,
you know,
it's not,
not the only thing that we talk about,
but we talk about,
uh,
his time,
you know,
coming up and making it and push it through people being negative little talk
about whiplash in there.
Uh,
I think it's a really interesting podcast even if you don't play drums.
And uh,
he got me some hilarious,
a couple of hilarious gifs and then one unbelievable one cause he's such a great
guy.
So please tune in.
I'll post that probably on Wednesday of this week.
So let's talk,
start talking some
dad.
Dad,
make me a fucking sandwich lady,
lady please.
Kitchen.
You know the houses are so close together out here.
I shouldn't be yelling.
Stuff like that.
You know,
I shouldn't.
Yeah,
yeah,
look at me again.
I'll give you another one.
Let's see if I can get the cops coming to my house.
Um,
I shouldn't do that.
Like Garrett blank referenced Gab.
Sorry,
I'm not going to do that.
But I do have the game on here and I actually have to,
uh,
I don't know.
I got a ton of Shit I got to do tomorrow.
So anyways.
Okay,
what do we do here?
What do we do?
Um,
I gotta tell you something right now.
I was what?
I watched the Green Seattle game and I am over it,
but I was absolutely fucking sick at the end of that game.
I'm not out of like a hate and Seattle kind of thing.
It was just that fucking prevent defense,
prevent or fencing.
I just,
for the life of me,
I mean it to work,
it has to,
it has to work.
Not only has,
does it have to work,
it has to work way more times than it doesn't work for them to continue the
insanity of playing football for 50 fucking minutes,
55 minutes.
And then in the end you just play,
not to lose that.
I Greenbay went into
Seattle.
They shut up the crowd.
Yeah,
they,
they handled,
they manhandled him through the first half.
And then when you know Seattle was going to come back and have a surge and they
handled that
five minutes to go,
they pick off Russell Wilson for the fourth fucking time.
You got the ball back.
All right,
let's fucking eat up some clock.
What?
What do they do?
They run the ball into the ass or this center three fucking times and then punt
it.
Yeah.
The,
I don't even think they took a minute off the clock.
Okay.
The whole game.
And you've got Aaron Rodgers is a quarterback.
Does he all of a sudden not know how to throw a fucking ball?
It's guys a super bowl champion.
Do you think he's fucking nervous?
The whole game you're playing to win and then in the end you've,
I,
it was fucking unbelievable.
I can't imagine what it'd be like the plane for the fucking packers.
Aaron Rodgers taking those play calls.
Okay.
You know?
All right,
man.
Five minutes ago,
what are we doing now?
What are you gonna dump it off to run it back.
We're going to post pattern.
What are we doing here?
Rod?
The ball up the battle.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah,
I get it.
Burnt a little clock here,
right?
Timeout.
Two seconds.
Three seconds off the clock.
All right,
coach.
Second down and 10 what are we doing?
How are we throwing the ball here,
right?
What are we gonna do?
A little play action.
Fake freeze.
The linebackers do.
Some here may pick up five,
six yards.
It up.
Blood battle.
Okay.
Rarely.
Hi.
Hey the boss,
right?
Oh,
tackle.
Timeout.
Now the two seconds off to fucking clock.
Third down at 10
okay.
Battery.
Is it fucking Aaron's warming up his arm.
What are we doing here?
Come on.
Who am I throwing it to?
Run it up.
The battle.
Yeah,
he fucking serious.
Okay.
The fuck are we doing right?
You don't want to throw the ball it into the ass crack of your center.
This is a recording.
Boom.
over Seattle doesn't take a timeout.
Greenbay kicks the ball away.
They take off fucking 50 seconds.
55 seconds off the clock.
Then what do they do?
Are they going to go back to play in football and get up in
their grills?
Okay.
Rush fucking Russell Wilson put them on his back like they have been the whole
gap.
Fuck that.
I got a better idea.
Let's go into the prevent.
Okay,
let's go into the fucking prevent defense,
which is basically we don't want to,
we don't want them to score on one big play.
Okay?
We'll protect the sidelines will give them the middle in 15 to 20 yard chunks
while they burn the clock or burn that time outs.
That's the philosophy.
So basically you don't give it up on one play.
You give it up on sixth place and you make every quarterback,
every quarterback who's ever faced a prevent defense immediately looked how Joe
Montana or John Elway,
oh,
Roger's star back used to look when and in the final two minutes of the game
when they actually played fucking defense as far as I remember.
So Seattle goes,
right.
You know,
you know what the F and I am literally,
where's my phone?
I fucking was texting Paul Versey.
You want to hear my tweets during the end of this fucking game?
All right,
here we go.
Let me scroll.
Jesus said coming in chunks coming in chunks.
Let's see here.
All right.
This is me.
After I watched him run the ball into the ass of their fucking center.
Three plays in a row and then punted all capitals.
What a fucking waste of a possession.
They are now going to ruin it.
Oh,
now that they're all that,
I think they still had one more run to go.
They are now going to run it.
Okay.
They just got,
Seattle is just going to take a timeout fucking eight seconds off the clock.
Now they've kicked the ball.
I right.
What was the strategy there?
Get the other team to use all the time outs.
They aren't even going to burn a minute off the clock on for fucking place.
Paul writes back,
I know now Seattle has the ball and I text.
They're literally going to get,
you're going to give this team a touchdown just so they can burn off time from
the clock.
I can't tell if that is good coaching or it is done by the league to give every
game possible.
A dramatic ending.
This is when I'm sitting there going,
I'm a comedian.
What the fuck do I know about,
about prevent the fits?
All I know is a fan watching.
Now obviously they scored.
I wrote fucking joke.
Yeah,
verse.
He wrote wild and he said,
no TD.
Thank God all that's when they throw it to Marshawn lynch.
Who by the way is the closest thing I've seen since Earl Campbell watching an
entire defense tried to tackle that man is like,
you haven't been drunk with your friends during the summertime and all the
windows of your car was down and you got everybody gets out of the car on a
small hill and all of a sudden you notice the car starts rolling and everybody
grabs onto it sliding in their tennis shoes trying to stop it.
Eventually.
You fucking do.
That's what it's like watching a defense.
Trying stop.
Marshawn Lynch fucking amazing.
Um,
then I go every fucking game,
Paul.
Every fucking game.
That stupid strategy makes every team look like the 40 niners in 1989.
Um,
okay,
now Greenbay okay,
they now are you.
I want to read the whole this whole fucking thing.
It's just basically,
okay,
I'll read the excerpts.
It's the dumbest fucking strategy I've ever seen in my life.
Green Bay packers deserve this.
They're fans don't.
Then in the end,
travesty in verse,
he said,
the problem was they kicked a gut feel goals instead of touchdowns.
There's nothing wrong with that.
If you're playing against the defense,
I feel is good is Seattle's.
You got to take what they're going to give you.
All right?
You kicked the field goals and then your defense was answering the call.
They answered the belt,
whatever the fucking cliche is,
and you had the fucking game.
One Green Bay had the ball back.
They had the ball,
they had their fucking destiny in their hands.
Go for a first down.
They,
if they got to first downs,
three first downs,
that fucking game is over.
Okay.
All right.
Sorry,
I'm back.
I actually knocked my recorder off.
I was saying I'm so fucking old that when I see people who run like me,
how bad I run.
They've played 17 years of quarterback and blew out an ACL.
Um,
anyway,
so I at the end of the game,
watching them,
watching them lose that game the way they did.
First of all,
congrats.
I didn't even say congratulation to Seattle.
Congratulations.
I mean,
it's not your fault.
They stop fucking playing.
And I guess to say that I'm taking away from your victory,
but I'm sure you've seen your team.
I think every football fan you've seen your team do that.
You've seen your team just playing football.
I'm not giving it up an inch.
I'm right up on you.
Fuck this.
We're winning this game.
And then you go to this whole like,
well,
you know,
I'll give you like [inaudible],
we'll give you a 10 yards,
15 yards.
But that's it.
I mean just,
it's just the exact,
yeah.
I don't know if the mentality of it,
I just don't,
I don't understand it.
It makes you know what it is about the prevent defense.
No game is out of reach.
You have to be like fucking up 21 points,
but if it's below 20
all of a sudden within five minutes if you're going to play that way,
it just seems like everything all of a sudden is in reach.
And then the de the announcers dramatical,
Tarnow Blah Blah.
Paula,
I who would never thought what when you start playing 20 yards off a guy,
when you stop calling any imagine of plays on offense and even Troy Aikman on
the third time was going like,
no,
I got a thrill like to go running in there and keep it on the ground.
It's like everybody knew it.
When you got to stand up comedians texting what the Green Bay packers are going
to do next,
that's probably not a good sign as far as if you're going to try and win a
fucking game.
Okay
Dude,
I was so,
I was so upset because I felt the pay,
you know,
I'm not looking past the colts either.
I know obviously anything can happen,
but if we were going to go to the Superbowl,
I got to think that uh,
for whatever reason we matched up better with green bay.
I just,
I just feel that the fact that we get for the most part,
no pressure on the quarterback and you got Russell who so mobile,
um,
that would present a problem and then we suck against the run for the most part.
And Marshawn Lynch,
even if you're good against them,
it takes at least what,
like six,
seven people just to kind of slow him down.
And Seattle's defense is unbelievable.
As annoying as they are,
how they stand over every person after they tackle them as if that person has
never been tackled before.
And as annoying is all those bandwagon fans are,
which was hilarious to see them locked out.
You know,
nobody who was at the kingdom back in the day left that game,
you know,
Goddamn well they going to stay there.
Even if they were going to lose,
they would have sat there and they would have cried like a real fan and then
walked out to your car with your head down.
It was always next year.
Right.
Um,
I have a tremendous amount of respect for,
uh,
for that organization.
I mean it's the fucking,
I mean obviously the teams that they put together is incredible.
Um,
but I would like to win the Superbowl,
so I would like to give my team the greatest chance.
So I was,
uh,
that was not the damn team that I wanted to play,
but um,
it's not even that the Seattle one,
it was the way green bay loss and I had to get in my fucking Prius,
fucking go for a drive.
And um,
I ended up in an Italian restaurant.
They make homemade pasta.
Right.
And I was right before dinner and they hadn't made that.
They were in the process of making the pasta and the sauce.
So I got an a,
I got a salad and then just a couple of meatballs and sat there and had a scotch
as the patriots are playing,
recording the game.
MMM.
Just dumbfounded how I watch green bay loose at fucking game.
And uh,
and somewhere halfway through that scotch that I was drinking,
it just became hilarious that my team was playing and I was so distraught over
to other teams that aren't my team.
That didn't knock my team out,
that I wasn't even watching my team,
even though I was recording it.
And just that whole thing of like,
why the fuck?
Why do I care this much?
And I'm,
I don't know,
it just kind of struck me as funny.
Then of course I'm talking to the bartender and you know,
he doesn't give a shit about,
well,
I guess maybe he could give a shit.
He just needed money.
So he was working.
I just assume if you've taken that shift,
you could at least fake sick or whatever.
Um,
so
anyways,
uh,
Jesus Christ two in a row at least it wasn't a bad call man.
But what the fuck?
What the fuck.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I don't have any,
uh,
any questions or anything this week.
How far into this?
I don't even know how many fucking minutes of any of this cause I don't,
I didn't look at the first one should probably,
uh,
Micah Dolan's is not only to packer fans,
but any fan of a fucking team that had to sit there and watch your team have a
game one and then go into the prevent defense.
I,
I'm really actually going to listen to sports talk radio tomorrow morning to try
and have some,
hopefully somebody will explain it.
Um,
there's another one,
I don't get five seconds left in the half for some fucking reason.
You squib kick it.
So then they get the ball in the 40.
Like how big a threat is that guy back in the end zone?
What are the odds?
He's going to take it to the 40
if they wanted to,
they probably won't,
but if they wanted to they could just fucking heave it to the end zone with
Andrew Lux arm.
Right.
I Dunno,
I don't fucking get it.
Um,
well,
Bill,
you're a comedian,
you're not supposed to get it.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
Um,
so anyways,
I got a,
uh,
I've got a crazy week coming up here.
Um,
you guys remembered a long time ago.
I did a movie out in New Orleans called black or white that started,
oh,
they took a knee.
It's nothing.
Why don't you throw the Hail Mary?
They used to do that.
What is the problem?
Um,
anyways,
I really sound like a crabby old man.
Why aren't they doing it the way that you start though?
It?
Uh,
all right.
So I did a movie a year and a half ago,
uh,
called black or white,
um,
starring Kevin Costner,
Octavia Spencer,
and I directed and written by Mike binder.
Um,
and uh,
it's finally coming out.
It's coming out on January 30th and a,
so we're doing all the promotion,
all the press and all that type of stuff this week,
which should be a,
hopefully a good time.
So I got a bunch of that type of shit coming up and uh,
I'm going to be on,
um,
real time with Bill Maher
on a,
on Friday.
And,
uh,
and then after that on Saturday,
I lead from my,
uh,
what the hell am I going?
I go to Australia,
New Zealand,
Singapore,
Hong Kong,
Mumbai,
all of that shit.
And I get back to just going back to being a comedian.
So I got basically a week of press here that I'm doing coming up.
Um,
I was in New Orleans this week.
I did an,
uh,
had a quick three day shoot and a,
an upcoming movie.
I never see what they are until they're coming out.
And then I make sure that I'm still in them.
So,
uh,
you know,
trying to keep my actor health insurance hanging in there,
the sag after shit.
So,
uh,
anyways,
let's do a little bit of advertising here for this week.
Uh,
what do we got here?
vegas.com for my listeners,
10% off everything excluding air hotel packages.
Oh,
so you basically got to get yourself there and put yourself up and then
everything else was 10% off.
Go to vegas.com right now when you book hotels,
show shows and activities get 10% off when you enter my code bur bur are they
really do serve up Vegas from the inside because unlike other travel sites,
they're from Vegas.
These are not outsiders.
These people are down there.
All right,
everyone@vegas.com lives in Vegas,
works in Vegas,
parties in Vegas,
pukes in Vegas,
top 10 Vegas must do's.
Take a photo at the welcome to fabulous Las Vegas Nevada sign.
He got to do that.
Shoot a Zombie in the face goes without saying drive a really fast car.
Sounds like,
and they drive a car really fast,
I should say.
It sounds like they're going to take you to that race track out there.
Jump off the stratosphere.
That's debatable.
Experience.
Elvis,
of course,
be a rock star for the day.
Why not hang out at a topless optional pool club?
Creamy dance like a stripper.
Get married at Denny's.
Enter my code bur bur and the Promo code at checkout and get an extra 10% off
everything but air hotel packages.
That's vegas.com and get your bonus savings with my secret code that I'm telling
everybody so it's no longer a secret.
Consider yourself on the inside.
[inaudible] B u.
R.
All right.
National Academy of Sports Medicine.
They are here.
Exclamation point.
New Year's resolutions.
Period.
Everyone's got one exclamation point.
Get in shape.dot dot.
Be healthier.dot dot.
Get a new job.
dot.dot.
Become a certified personal trainer with the National Academy of Sports
Medicine.
And you can do all three.
The fitness industry is booming.
Of course it is.
Baby boomers are still on treadmills,
you know that blowing up their knees and their hips,
they getting the plant or Fisher radius,
whatever the hell it is.
The fitness industry is booming in the demand for personal training is soaring.
I can't feel my legs.
Imagine waking up every day excited by the fact that people are hurt and you're
going to make money off of them.
I can not a job,
but a rewarding career,
getting paid to stay in shape while helping others to reach their fitness goals.
Oh,
this is at least a personal trainers.
I don't know what I'm selling here.
I'm a whore.
Um,
you set your own hours,
you work in health clubs,
sports clinics,
and core corporate wellness and you'll love who you work with.
Finally,
do what you truly enjoy and get paid for it.
This is a pretty cool job.
Get ahead on 2015 and begin your certification with the National Academy of
Sports Medicine.
Now,
if you don't land a job as a personal trainer within 60 days of certification,
they'll give you your money back.
Guaranteed.
Oh,
it's a personal trainer.
Sorry.
Geez,
that's pretty cool,
Huh?
If you don't get a job in two months,
call to action.
Go To my USA trainer.com for a free 14 day sneak peek of their fast and fun
online program.
That's my USA trainer.com.
My USA trainer.com re uh,
restrictions apply.
Visit my USA trainer.com for details.
And then the last one here,
I'm going to read draft kings.com yeah,
season ending.
Long fantasy football league may be over,
but there's plenty of excitement.
Sorry you had a scotch,
but there's plenty of excitement every week at draft kings that can't turn
story.
Dave from Boston won $1 million and one day just playing fantasy football.
So did Matt from Florida and Ray from New Jersey,
Ray aggy and fucking a million euro.
You're fed code.
In fact,
draft kings is crowned a new millionaire nearly every week.
This season.
The football action even continues throughout the playoffs@draftkings.com and be
sure to check out their exciting moneymaking contests and other sports too,
like hockey and college and pro hoops.
You've been hearing about big witness at draftkings all year.
Now it's your turn to whinge huge cash.
Well now it's your turn to try to win huge cash or you could give up your money
and be part of that mountain of cash that they keep and they divvy off a little
bit to one lucky winner.
Evidently someone from Florida call the action.
Had to draft kings.com now and use the Promo code defense to play for free and
hundreds of thousands of dollars fainted and 100 and the hundred thousand dollar
fantasy football contest this weekend.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winners,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense for every entry now@draftkings.com draftkings.com what is that
everybody say with me?
Draft kings.com.
All right,
let's go back to this.
Um,
oh,
I did another one of the goddamn comedy jam,
uh,
this weekend with Josh Adam Meyers.
And,
uh,
we actually did,
um,
I did a Pentair or song cowboys from health was the song that I chose to do
despite the fact that I don't play double bass.
And,
uh,
Mike Double Bass playing was,
was,
uh,
it was pretty horrific,
but it was way better than I was before I decided to do that song.
Um,
I dressed up like Vinnie Paul.
I made an ass of myself and uh,
but it's fun.
You know,
it was cool was I sat down behind the kid,
I wasn't nervous at all,
which is a,
which is a good thing because usually there's a,
um,
you know,
cause I'm stepping outside myself,
but you know,
you just keep doing it,
doing it,
doing it then all of a sudden just becomes,
oh yeah,
I'm doing this show again.
I've done it before.
I know what I got to do,
blah,
blah.
And uh,
you know,
it's funny.
That sound was really bad.
We were outside in a tent.
It's way better when it's,
when they have the show over on the brave because you can actually,
you know,
the sound was tremendous.
They had to turn down the sound because we were playing riot fest.
It's some sort of comedy festival that they have in downtown La.
And people were complaining about the noise,
not even from the music.
They were complaining about how loud the stand ups or I guess there was a
apartment building right next door.
So my apology to those people.
But um,
yeah,
went up there and I had a,
I had a good time.
So I have no idea what the next one I'm going to do is if you guys have any
requests,
you know,
I'm be,
I'm basically asking you guys to give me an idea of what song I should fucking
play next because I'm kind of out of ideas.
I played a Zepplin one dress like John Bonham,
Motley Crue,
Tommy Lee,
and I did Pantera.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't know.
Let the double Bass Golf.
I don't want to do a novel now the double Bass Song,
but if anybody knows a good one,
uh,
if you learned how to play Double Bass,
obviously starting with Vinnie,
Paul is not an easy thing.
If you know a pan terra song that,
uh,
cause if you played double bass,
I would imagine that cowboys from hell is pretty straight forward.
Um,
as far as the tempo is not that bad.
If you know something else along those lines.
That's sort of the next thing because I always felt like if you're learning how
to play drums for me,
if you learn,
if you're a white guy,
he knew playing rock drums.
For me it was you started with ACDC,
right?
You learned the whole foreign,
the floor to for fucking thing.
Right?
And then the next thing I would do is then you move to like guns and roses,
appetite for destruction.
Well maybe we even went up to Charlie watts.
If you're going to baby step your way up so it's a little more busy bass drum,
you know.
And uh,
then I would go appetite for destruction and then from there it would basically
be like whatever direction you want it to go.
And,
and here I am talking about drums again.
I don't know,
supposed to be talking about anyone.
What the fuck I'm supposed to be talking about here?
Um,
anyways,
Hey,
I saw that movie boyhood.
Did you guys see that shit?
It's pretty interesting where they have uh,
basically the,
cause they shot the movie over 12 years and you get to watch this little boy
that they cast grow up.
Oh my God.
Here we go again.
Domestic violence and sexual assaults are hard subjects for everyone to talk
about.
So let's show all these people crying,
right?
Who does,
what are they going to do next?
Funerals.
What you actually cared about the person who died or hard to talk about.
And then I have to watch people crying
for the love of God.
Who were those fucking commercials for?
Does the person who sexually assault someone just sees Hillary swank crying and
then goes,
you know what,
I'm going to stop sexually assaulting people.
I don't,
I don't for the fucking life of me who doesn't care about victims
of basically anything.
Did the what did they,
are they trying to move me to do what?
What are they trying to do?
I think they're trying to get my
money on some level,
right?
So that they can siphon off 20% of it so they can go out and go buy themselves a
pink Bentley and then they throw some money at the,
uh,
you know,
no more backhands docket org,
whatever the fuck they're doing.
I just for the life of me,
those fucking goddamn commercials and as annoying as those are,
I don't understand why you kicking other team's fucking ass for 55 minutes and
then decide to lay down on the goddamn ground for the final,
your own choice.
Okay.
Your own fucking choice.
Um,
God dammit.
I liked it.
I liked Seattle.
I really liked that fucking team,
but I just cannot stand all the fucking pomp and circumstance around it.
Did you guys see that they have two giant screens,
allegedly measuring how loud the fucking crowd is?
I mean,
isn't it enough that they built a fucking stadium to try to just hold those
people's hands and to trying to sound like they give a fuck?
What else do they have to do to coerce these people into cheering every God damn
game.
They gotta have some fucking war vet or fucking 80 at eight 1980s action hero
come out and wave a fucking Hanky to get them all excited.
You're not excited.
It's a fucking playoff game.
You're going to try to be the first team to repeat and like 10 fucking years.
That's not enough excitement.
Yeah.
You know,
you need frank Stallone to come out there and swing a dirty diaper over his
fucking oh yeah.
Try.
We're supposed to give a fuck.
Ah,
worst stressed fans.
Who are you going with?
Honorary mentions gotta be the black hole.
Oakland Raiders.
That absolute fucking shit.
Show of humanity.
I would say Cleveland Browns,
the dog pound.
If they put them on TV more.
Remember that when they used to bark at the camera and,
and dog biscuits and you're supposed to sit at home going,
wow,
these people are crazy.
They had money,
legal tender to buy football tickets and they went to their assigned seat.
Uh,
Jesus fucking Christ with the pretend crazy.
I gotta be honest with you.
The person who's really just going to fucking knock you out and make you
fucking,
you know,
ate the rest of your meals for the rest of your life.
Sipping through a fucking Straw is not the guy that's dressed up like a dog or
the dude with the spikes coming out of his fucking shoulder pads.
It's going to be that quiet guy with the dirty hat.
The dude with the neck tattoo,
it's going to be that person because they know that they're crazy and they know
that they're going to fuck somebody up.
And the last thing they want to do is fucking puts somebody in a coma and then
run out of a stadium,
dress like big bird.
Cause they're going to get caught.
They want it,
they want to blend in with the fucking crowd.
Wouldn't you think?
Am I out of my mind to think that shit?
I have no idea.
So anyways,
I just heard a fucking plane fly over my head.
I'm actually studying for my exam next month to get my,
uh,
my license and I'm not going to fly here for the next uh,
couple of weeks due to my schedule and all that type of shit.
So I am literally studying,
um,
bringing my notebooks with me,
taking practice tests.
Ah Shit.
I should have had some of that stuff in front of me.
I should have taken one of those God damn test all this type of shit.
You have to know.
If you're flying east to west and you slow down,
you know which way's the needle going to point as they can to point down towards
the south of the north on your fucking compass.
I already can't even fucking remember.
I've answered that question so many fucking times.
They still forget when you're flying east,
when you fly east to west,
you fly at an even altitude plus 500 west to east.
You fly an odd plus 500 so you wouldn't fly at 5,000 you fly at 5,500 you go on
the other way.
You'd fly four thousand five hundred and four thousand all of that shit plus all
this shit about the weather.
All right.
What do you go to your second half is starting.
How about fucking Amygdala?
Is this guy been stepping up or what?
I was like most people,
I thought the guy,
like every time he went to go pick up his helmet,
he blew out his hamstring and Al of a sudden to me he had such a fucking,
I didn't really talk about the game last week.
I was so fucking,
uh,
on my period about the Dez Bryant catch.
That wasn't a catch.
And uh,
I dunno,
when am I going to learn?
I can't fucking have the TV on and try to fucking riff on this God damn thing.
Think.
Oh by the way,
can we talk about that lady?
The fucking,
there's a woman out there.
Um,
she fucking was married to a guy who was a billionaire.
She's getting a divorce.
The guy wrote her a check just under a billion dollars and she turned it down.
Now I know what a lot of people are thinking.
What a fucking gold digging whore.
This is right up bills.
Alley.
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to tweet a fucking link to this article and this will get them going
on the podcast and then he'll have a shit fit.
And I'll laugh as I'm sitting in my cubicle.
Well,
surprise,
surprise.
I'm not really having a shit fit about this cause I don't think it's about the
money.
This is the deal.
This broad.
All right,
this fucking twinkle toes here and I know a little fucking sugar tits here.
She married this guy.
This guy was worth 50 million bucks.
He was an oil man.
Get off my fucking property right now.
Global warming.
Good.
I liked that.
There's a hole in the ozone layer.
Makes me feel like I'm closer to God,
right?
He's an oil man.
Hey,
I'll tell you what,
Mr President,
I mean,
know why I have to call you Mr President.
I fucking put you in office with my God damn money.
Look at me when I'm talking to you or bomber.
Alright.
My granddaddy put that dictator in fucking power and he was supposed to give us,
are a little gold little shit there,
right?
He's supposed to give us our liquid gold.
Right?
He ain't doing it no more.
You gotta go over there.
You got to take that fucker out.
You understand me?
I'll give a fuck how you do it.
He's an oil man.
It's a fucking oil man.
Alright,
he's got slim Whitman on laser disk,
right?
Oh,
it's Irish.
What was the fucking Slim Whitman?
He sold over 9 million records.
Um,
anyways,
I'm all over the fucking map.
You'll see I'm back to me.
I'm not looking at the TV anymore.
MMM.
So this fucking guy he's got,
he's got a $50 million business.
This,
he already has this.
And this woman does not sign a fucking,
he doesn't sign a prenup with the woman.
According to her,
she didn't take the billion dollar payout because now 26,
27,
28 fucking years later,
they going for doors.
This guy's company is worth $20 billion according to her.
All right?
Nay is the thing.
She's like,
I was with this guy and I supported him and blah,
held down the fucking home front and all that.
That's gotta be worth something.
This was fucking crazy to me.
It's like,
you know,
with all due respect,
sweetheart,
this guy made 50 million without you.
Okay,
look,
I could see if the guy had a couple hundred grand in the bank.
All right?
Maybe.
All right.
Whatever.
You know what I mean?
You make $50 million.
Give me a fucking break.
You started out with nothing and you worth $50 million.
Are you fucking,
you know what you're doing at that point.
Once you have $50 million,
that's,
that's when,
that's when you got your own.
You can starting to have your own plane.
You're in a gated community.
You got your own security system,
you know,
you fucking kill somebody and the cops go down to your house and they're talking
to your lawyer and the driveway is,
you're sitting there eating fucking escargo on an English muffin and they're
asking your fucking lawyer,
if you,
if you wouldn't mind turning yourself in over the next six,
seven days,
you like that level,
fucking rich.
And once you that level rich,
it's fall.
It's all fucking downhill.
Okay.
You meet and the people that are running the world,
you meet the people in the Bilderberg group.
Yeah.
Meet the people in the other groups that I don't know about or what the fuck
they talk about,
but I pretend like I do.
You're at that level of fucking wealth.
All right?
So this fucking guy grows it to $20 billion and she gets a check for a billion
jet basically.
And,
uh,
she says she doesn't want it.
Okay.
She wants more.
So everybody is saying that she's a gold digger whore.
You know what I really think it is?
And she's saying that she supported them and helped to build,
say go fuck yourself.
All right,
let's,
let's just say for whatever fucking,
I met an unknown lady Gaga in the East Village 10,
12 fucking years ago.
Right?
And she's down there ripping off Madonna songs or whatever.
I'm like,
you know what?
There's something about her though.
You know,
she's got nice legs.
He's getting a nice ass.
I mean,
I like the imperfections.
I like the giant nose.
Look at me.
I got red fucking hair.
It's falling out.
I think we could make a good couple.
You know what?
Both the mess,
two negatives,
make a positive.
We'll make a beautiful baby.
So I started fucking hanging out with the next thing you know,
we fall in love,
Garrett.
Um,
so then we think,
uh,
all right.
You know,
we get married.
Okay.
And let's just say whatever I'm doing,
I'm fucking,
I make keys.
That's what I do.
That's my job.
Okay.
And she's out down there.
She's down in the village and she's fucking,
you know,
she's making her own meat dress.
You know,
she's going out,
she's making money in a coffee house and she goes right to the Deli and she buys
more meat.
She's investing in herself,
she's building her career,
she's playing the fucking piano,
she's coming home.
And she's like,
what do you think of this?
And I'm like,
God,
Hey,
right,
I'm over there.
I'm knitting a fucking sweater.
You know,
I've got a pot roast in the Goddamn oven or whatever.
Okay.
And then she becomes lady Gaga.
I get to quit my fucking job,
Mr Gaga.
I get to go on Oprah and sit there silently,
you know,
as Oprah talks to lady for fucking an hour.
And then finally she says,
Whoa,
what do you see it here?
And then I already have some prewritten speech about how I'm Gaga about Gaga,
Gaga for Gaga or whatever the fuck happens,
right?
And let's just say in the end to all of that,
I'm walking down the fucking hall,
blinded by her gold records or platinum records and all that shit.
Every morning when I go to brush my teeth,
I got to fucking,
I got to put on my,
uh,
my amber visions just to get there so I don't fucking walk into the walk in
closet instead of the bathroom,
let's say at the end of that,
she gets sick of me and she kicks me to the fucking curb.
All right?
And let's say she's worth $100 million and she turns around and says,
I'm going to give you bill.
I'm going to write you a check.
Let's do the same thing.
Let's say I said 20 billion.
Just say she's worth 20 million.
And she says,
Bill,
I'm going to give you $1 million.
And you know what I'm going to say?
I want to say thank you,
lady Gaga.
Okay?
It was awesome.
I enjoyed,
I was just making keys.
I wasn't going to make $1 million in my lifetime.
All right,
I'm going to take this money and I'm going to pay my taxes on it,
but to get myself a little fucking house,
okay?
You know,
and I'm going to make keys in the back of it.
I'm going to get my life back and I'm going to find,
I have,
God knows you gave me plenty of fog and I would buy,
you know what I would do with that?
I would go buy a fuck.
Everybody needs keys.
Touchdown.
Who the fuck was that?
Who've just scored that Nate's salt.
Just scored his first,
first touchdown ever.
Nice.
23 seven.
Oh,
did we match up better against the packers?
So anyway,
I'll look at our two cheaters talking there
on the sidelines to convicted Cheetahs.
That was a nice play.
That was nice place.
How'd you like the video?
I love the video.
Um,
anyways,
you're going to have a sense of humor,
but you don't fucking team,
don't you?
Most people don't,
but I do.
Um,
anyways,
so let's go back here.
Uh,
yeah,
she gave me 1 million bucks.
What I would do is I would find a house.
Okay.
That cost,
like,
I don't know,
like 150 grand,
you know?
And I would put down a ridiculous amount of money on it and then I put the rest
of the money away and I would start cutting keys again out of the back of my
house and I get that business going and I would fucking build it up.
And then I go on to a set of farmers only.com I go on like a key makers only.com
and I try to meet somebody else.
That's what the fuck I would do.
I would never try to take her money.
It'd be like,
you know what?
I know I gave you support.
I know I said that was a beautiful song.
I know you wrote a couple songs about us instead of Dear Ben,
you wrote,
dear bill,
I get it,
but I can't sing.
I can't play a fucking piano.
Whose kid know?
We both know why I lived the life I live for the last 10 years.
It was because of you,
lady Gaga and the think I got to live that life.
And in the end of it,
you're going to give me 1 million bucks to leave.
Yeah.
You're a fucking sates.
I still love you lady Gaga,
even though you don't love me anymore.
I don't know why you love me in the,
that's probably why you liked such wonderful thought there.
Connects with an entire demographic of people.
Continued success.
Thank you for that million dollars.
And I would fucking leaf.
All right.
I got too much fucking pride to sit there.
If somebody doesn't fucking want me
to then try to take everything they got.
I mean,
just,
I,
I couldn't fuck the second,
somebody didn't want me around like,
all right,
Jeez.
I didn't know it was annoying you.
I get it.
Sorry.
Can I grab my things now?
Do you want to want me to send somebody else?
I would just get the fuck out of there.
Um,
so anyway,
so that seems to be,
you know,
this lady here that she,
she got $1 billion,
um,
and she says it's not enough.
What I honestly think it is,
I just think it's an emotional thing for this woman.
I don't think it's a money thing because you can't spend that.
You can't spend all that fucking money.
Right.
Did you guys,
they actually showed a copy of the,
uh,
of the check that this dude to his ex wife,
he didn't write it on one of those business checks,
you know,
that are sorta extra long and the whole extra area of the memo section that you
write stuff,
he wrote it on like a personal little check,
like the same kind of check,
like you know,
somebody live in week to week.
There's the one was a little checkbooks.
He wrote a check for like 989 million,
$899,000 and 31 cents,
whatever the fuck it was.
And I think what he did was,
it's guys obvious,
I dunno what the fuck.
Maybe he's just good at business.
I think he just sat down after they decided on the number and I bet he did it
right in front of her after 26 fucking years.
Okay.
He's walking away,
he's leaving and he just sits down and he's just writing money just to make her
leave.
And he just sits down and goes,
scribble,
sign,
sign dot.
The I cross the fucking t,
tears it out.
He'd go beat it,
lady.
I just think it came across like that and it fucking pisses her off.
And she's just like,
this is the thing,
the worst thing you can have when a woman's breaking up with you or if you're
breaking up with a woman,
is if she's not over you,
if she's over you,
it's going to go smoothly.
You don't have to deal with her fucking,
you know,
putting up your,
your pet rabbit and a god damn stew.
All right?
But if they're not over you,
you got a fucking let them down easy.
You can't just push them down.
The emotional elevator shaft.
All right,
you're going to have a major fucking problem.
And I think this guy,
he just fucking fired off the check.
Like he was paying another bill and I,
she just was insulted by that.
And she's think doing the math.
And I had like,
you know,
this motherfucker's gonna actually you talked a little bit about this on the
Chris Layton podcast,
so I forgive me if there's a little bit of overlap,
but I just wanted to hear what he thought about it.
Um,
okay.
I think that uh,
Aye.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I just think that they want you,
they want you to hurt.
They just want you to hurt.
I don't know what it is.
Not all of them,
just some of them.
And I think that she didn't get a sad enough of a satisfied heart.
Look on this guy's face.
There wasn't enough pain.
I think he just treated her like he had to get the gutters fixed and at some
professional come over and did it and he just fired off this fucking check and
it just pissed her off.
They all cause she's more than taking care of for the rest of her fucking life.
Anything that you could ever watch,
it's all good.
But I think the fact that he still has so much more money and it didn't hurt him
to write that check
that and she knows that he has enough money to get like,
you know when you got $20 billion,
there's like a Victoria secret model that will pretend to give a fuck about you
for a good year,
year and a half.
And you could do that for the rest of your life as you're ride around in
Ferrari's now her,
she's a woman,
guys don't work that way.
We don't really give a shit money.
You know,
one more like enamored by looks,
you know,
it's both of our fucking weaknesses.
Whatever you guys are into stuff.
We were into fucking
tits and ass.
So which is why you know,
we will date somebody is dumb as a fucking rock and you will also date some ugly
old balding Douche,
you know,
because they can take care of you.
It's kind of what we do.
So I'm not really,
a lot of people wanted me to go off on her like she's a gold digging whores.
I don't think she has.
I think she's,
I think she's hurt and she's heard how easy this guy is.
Just getting over.
I know.
All you guys are sitting there going like,
dude,
what the fuck?
He's writing her a check for $1 billion.
I know that hurts,
dude.
You got $20 billion.
Come on man.
If that's true,
if it's true,
and you got $20 billion outright,
yeah.
Fucking check for up for a bill.
That wouldn't hurt me at all.
There you go.
Big Bang.
Boom.
Bated whistle on Dixie.
Jesus Christ.
The fucking interest alone on that money you'd get by the time you walked down
the driveway or she walks down the driveway leaving you,
you're money is probably already made fucking $30 million.
The fuck.
Do you care?
Um,
I know he's probably,
that's obviously not 20 billion liquid.
It's got a lot of that tied up and Derek,
right?
Some giant fucking ranches,
some oil rags trucks.
Um,
other that Pat's van
that look like Jim Loleta.
Um,
comedian.
I,
I knew back in Boston,
uh,
drinking is Sam Adams there.
Anyways,
it's 24 to seven nine oh nine left to go in the third quarter.
Yeah.
Patriots d is looking good,
but I just don't think there's anything in the AFC that was,
is really going to,
uh,
can get you ready for what Seattle's going to be bringing on a d.
At least a defensive level.
Uh,
I dunno,
that was,
I probably one of the worst games is a pro that Russell Wilson has had.
I have no,
I really don't have,
I don't have any idea what's going to happen.
I like if the Patriots play Seattle in the Superbowl,
it will not surprise me if we win or we get absolutely ass raped.
I have no fucking idea.
I've watched that little amount of football,
um,
this year because I've been so fucking busy.
Um,
but that's going to be amazing.
And how about Robert Kraft?
Huh?
I know I've mentioned this before.
What a fucking owner.
He is three coaching hires,
Bill Parcells unknown Pete Carroll as far as like at the pro level and then bill
Bellacheck.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
That now is a,
he's basically these two guys looking like they're going to face each other and
the super bowl.
Uh,
I would love to hear that conversation.
I wonder if,
I wonder if they've ever talked since he fired them.
Sure.
We sent them some sort of fucking,
um,
the fuck was it one 800.
What was that thing?
When I lost my shit when I was reading it and I can't remember.
What the fuck was it?
Fruit baskets.org.
I forget me undies.
Everybody.
And we go again.
Me undies be undies.
No more sweaty balls,
but boop,
boop,
me undies,
me undies.
You can buy a,
at the fucking mall.
Walk up to a fucking chick.
You don't have to worry that she takes her to stick.
Oh,
you are wearing fucking me undies.
You got no sweaty balls.
Oh,
Yay.
You can talk to the fucking chick.
Well,
get yourself some know,
more sweaty balls.
90%.
That's the percent of your life that you're in your underwear there,
right?
Um,
and underwear,
it gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear.
You need to know the feeling of great fitting underwear that it's two times
softer than cotton.
You need to know about me undies,
me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Me undies.com [inaudible] is the most comfortable underwear you will ever wear.
Four out of five ball bag.
Say we love me undies and it's insane how good they make you feel.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on your fucking ass crack and they literally pull moisture
away from your skin growth so you can stay cool.
Personalize.
I have mine on right now.
I didn't.
I had them on earlier and I am floating.
I wouldn't say I'm floating around.
I was comfortable.
You know what?
I wore them last night when I was pretending to be Vinnie Paul and that's the
best I ever played live.
And who am I giving credit to?
Josh,
Adam Meyers.
Nope.
Me undies.
I'm fucking butcher and double bass.
Uh,
I can't even tell you how great I feel when I'm staying cool and comfortable
down there all day.
Oh,
these are all examples of stuff that I'm supposed to say.
It's such a profound impact to the way I feel.
If don't say impact around your balls anyways,
they're great.
I've tried them on Gras for a first down.
I've tried them.
They have cool styles for both men and ladies.
Oh good man.
He used to be under,
you know,
more clammy twats oh yeah.
And look great.
Check out the photos yourself at me undies Dotcom.
This quality would typically retail for two times the me Andy price according to
them.
No retail middlemen means more savings to you.
Here.
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order for free
and free shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
I got to tell you,
I've warned them.
Uh,
they're great.
They're nice and thin too.
You know what I mean?
They're not cumbersome.
So if you were,
if you one of those people that wears your hipster jeans,
you know where they're tight yet sagging off your lack of an ass,
I think that this is the underwear for you.
Then they come in very bright,
noticeable.
Notice my ass colors,
I think.
I think,
I think that the perfect underwear for you.
All right,
stamps.com everybody trips to the post office are never convenient,
so why not get postage right from your desk with stamps.com
stamps.com even gives you special posts,
special postage discounts you you can't get at the post office,
including FirstClass priority mail express international and more.
You'll never have to pay full price for postage again.
Here's how stamps.com works.
Everybody oh first,
no,
no.
First down,
fuck.
Okay,
Brandon Lafell.
Um,
here we go.
Here's how stamps.com works.
Using your own computer and printer.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package.
They just hand your bail to the mailman or drop it in a mailbox.
Fuck,
I got the hiccups now.
It's just that easy.
It's no wonder over 500,000 small businesses are already using stamps.com I use
stamps.com anytime I make a poster poster to send out to people do send out the
venue so I can sell them to people at the end of the show.
And I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you right now use my last name bur bur to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
bar dollar shave club.
Don't you know,
I just realize how spoiled I am as a fan that we are up by 17 points and I'm
sitting here doing a podcast with the game on mute in the background.
We've gone to so many fucking super bowls.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's fucking ridiculous.
I need to,
I need to appreciate this more.
I think that was the first time,
wasn't it all the puzzle when they blew the whistle?
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Can someone tell me when razors got so goddamn expensive,
if I have been asleep for 20 years,
is that what happened?
I was in a store the other day and one pack of razors is now 20 bucks.
One pack people.
That is crazy,
but hey,
sometimes they give you a free gift when you buy their overprice razors,
which is ash,
which is actually just a punch in the Dick Financially speaking.
That is don't get beat up by ridiculous razor prices.
Get your shave gear where I get mine from.
Dollar Shave club.com for just a few bucks.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors and other great grooming supplies
right to your doorstep.
I'm waiting for them to dollar shave club to make a hot comb for your pubes.
Uh,
do a little Fred Frederick Douglass down there.
Surprise the ladies.
Uh,
their plan starts at just $3.
Here's how it works.
They sent me the candle for free and every month they send me replacement
blades.
It's one less thing to worry about.
You can get deliveries every month or every other month.
However the hell you want to do it.
They got lots of other grooming supplies too.
You know.
I love the one wipe Charlies.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
sorry.
I just want you to Edelman catch a pass.
Why pay $20 for Raiders,
Raiders for razors when you can get that fantastic shave from dollar shave
club.com
for a fraction of the price.
Stop getting smacked around by high razor prices.
Dollar Shave club.com razors are great and they are a fraction of the price.
Trust me,
you wish you'd done it sooner.
Don't be a dumb ass.
Shaves smarter.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] you know I have to say it three times.
Say with me,
dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right.
Hey,
I bought those Bruins.
Huh?
They finally for the first time this year put together a nice run there.
They,
uh,
they played six games without losing winning five in a row and they lost one and
overtime,
but they still picked up a point unless the other night they lost to the
Columbus blue jackets.
But,
uh,
it's starting to hopefully play up to,
up to their potential.
I love whenever,
whenever they have a fucking problem.
Do you know,
somebody actually texted me and they said that they should trade Lou Cheech or
trade Brad Marshawn.
It's like,
are you fucking mind?
Yeah,
let's trade the guys that get the fucking team going.
Okay.
You know,
I just,
for the life of me,
I just don't understand the panic and they always pick like the star.
I think people who say that just,
they don't watch the game,
they just fucking,
they just,
they watched the stars.
Like if the Patriots start losing this,
remember earlier this year,
they started blaming Tom Brady say,
and he's,
is he past his prime?
Um,
I didn't think that,
but I was also one of those people that thought that the,
I thought the Patriots were finished after that.
Uh,
was it Kansas City game?
And then we came against the Bengals.
I thought it was,
um,
I definitely thought that we were done,
because I just felt like we kept,
uh,
I think he can hear it on one of my podcasts,
I was saying how we had this formula where we would basically,
okay
have a veteran player and w right when the guy was getting his second or his
second to last or his last contract and he wanted big money,
we would always trade the person away to stay under the cap or whatever.
And then we'd play some with somebody that didn't have experience and then we
would be,
we'd get that position for a while.
We just kept doing that all the way around on offense and defense and I,
I dunno,
Trade Logan Mankins look like a bad fucking move,
but the genius of Bella check when the drive a Brady,
um,
and the defense and all that,
I was wrong.
So I've been wrong about a lot of shit and I don't think we match up well
against Seattle.
So I think I,
I'm hoping I'm going to be wrong against that.
Granted there's still,
you know,
plenty of fucking time left in this game.
I'm talking about it like we already won.
Um,
anyways,
how far into this are we?
46 minutes.
I forget how long I talked to the,
I don't want to feel like you're going to talk to at least 15 minutes.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm gearing up for this.
Um,
okay.
Does standup tour that I have coming up and a,
I'm going to be playing,
doing a United stand up,
running my hour hit flappers
possibly another place going to be bouncing around La all this week.
Uh,
getting ready to go.
Just going back to being a fucking comedian again.
I can't wait to do it.
I am so ridiculously excited to,
uh,
go out to Southeast Asia and uh,
even all this time,
you know,
I'm not spending a lot of time in any of these places,
but this is how I handled Europe.
I just kept going there,
just business,
business,
business.
And then once I started selling tickets,
I was actually able to slow down and,
uh,
taking some sites.
So I plan on doing that throughout Southeast Asia.
So there's some quick things then I'm going to do when I go to Hong Kong,
I don't know how long I'm going to be there,
but at some point I'm going to get some fucking dumplings.
Touchdown.
Sorry.
There we go.
Now it's going to be 31 to seven.
So it's looking pretty good here.
MMM.
Paul Versey would've called this game at 14.
Nothing.
It's all,
it's all
I got to smoke a cigar with that guy.
Jesus Christ.
It's been a while.
So when I go to a Hong Kong,
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm definitely gonna try to get dumpling somewhere.
When I go to India,
uh,
India I think is going to be,
I don't know,
I think that that's going to be actually a bigger culture shock than when I go
to like Shanghai in and,
um,
and Hong Kong,
this might be ignorant of me,
but I feel like I've gone to a Chinatown enough times.
You know what I mean?
I've gone to San Francisco and gone down there and you walk there and there's
just so many people,
uh,
Asian people that you follow for the most part feel like you are somewhere in
Asia.
But I've never been to,
towns don't really have like a little India,
you know,
they have little Italy,
Italy,
little Armenia,
Thai town,
they'll have Chinatown on that type of stuff.
But I've never gone to a place where I was just surrounded by nothing but Indian
people.
So I think it's going to be a,
and an amazing experience.
And I had a buddy of mine who actually one of my flight instructors was just
over in Hong Kong and he said it's the coolest city he's ever been to hands
down,
which is so fucking awesome to hear.
Um,
okay.
And uh,
I also like China anyways just because they were,
the underdogs were as far as ain't little.
I know about Asia,
like Japan was signing kind of like the white people over there where they are
like,
we are the supreme people and we're now going to try to enslave everybody over
there.
You know what I mean?
Um,
they were sorta the,
they are the European mentality and a,
I don't know,
everybody else is sort of the underdog,
so I don't know.
There's just something about it.
Something I read about Bruce Lee one time I read this thing that uh,
okay,
the Japanese back in the day so that the Chinese were animals.
So
sleep was fighting in this Chinese style,
defeating these shogun warriors.
And after he kicks their ass in the movie,
he says,
by the way,
I'm not an animal.
And in China they like the movie say to just stood up and gave a standing
ovation.
I was like,
that's the shit.
I hope that's true.
So anyways,
I'm looking forward to going over there and uh,
it's killing me that I won't be anywhere near the Great Wall of China because a,
that's definitely on my bucket list.
But I figure if I keep going over to Hong Kong and a,
I can build up a following over there.
Eventually I'll make enough money where I could then blow it on another.
I figured I gotta jump on another plane.
I don't even know where the Great Wall is.
Is it in Beijing?
I know I can't jump in a fucking Prius over there and drive to it.
Uh,
I would be terrified to do it because I figured once I get out of Hong Kong,
the road signs are no longer in English and I would be fucked.
Uh,
Singapore,
it fascinates me.
Uh,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I am nervous that I am going to say something on stage that will get me caned.
Uh,
I promise you if I get into that situation,
I will try to remain calm enough before the first strike to yell out dough
Jesus.
Yo Jay Jay's before then and then any bitchy sounds I make after that.
I don't want to fucking hear it unless you got caned.
Um,
and then I have all of Australia and New Zealand and uh,
I just think it's going to be,
uh,
you know,
come on man.
This is like some shit that people bid on it at the end of the fucking price is
right.
And I get to do it while telling jokes.
Man.
I'm pretty much,
I'm pretty much stealing money.
Not to mention when I go over there,
my biggest fucking problem is going to be,
uh,
cigars because Cuban cigars or legal over there.
And I kind of made a new year's resolution that I was going to smoke only one a
week because you figure that's still 52 fucking cigars a year.
That's a lot of fucking cigars.
Unless you smoke cigars,
then it's a joke.
So,
um,
for the month of January,
I unfortunately have already smoked five.
I smoked one at the Rose Bowl,
then I smoked too during the Patriots game last week I spoke to in New Orleans
and um,
that was going to smoke one today.
I was like,
I can't,
cause I'm already for the allotted time are already into February,
so I have to somehow get through this week and my first fucking a week of
Australia without smoking.
But I gotta tell ya today,
you know,
uh,
today it was tough.
I got a nice back porch area,
was really calling to me.
Jesus Christ.
I really,
I,
I am addicted to those fucking things.
I've got to admit it.
I'm fucking addicted and I got to work on that.
But anyways,
yeah,
that is the podcast for this week.
Uh,
congratulations to the Seattle Seahawks franchise and all the fans that stayed
it all the ones that were back there when the kingdom,
ah,
my condolences to all fucking fans of the Green Bay packers.
Um,
can anybody,
anybody who was in code,
there's gotta be somebody in coaching,
you know,
I don't give a shit what level you coach.
Can you please explain to me the prevent defense and just,
do you have any numbers?
It has to work way more than it doesn't work.
Um,
I don't know.
I just think as a fan,
I hate it because even if we win,
I still have to go to fucking,
the amount of stress that it puts me through just drives me up the fucking wall.
It's just like you've been kicking their ass.
Just keep kicking their fucking ass.
Can Anybody at coaching please?
For the love of God,
help me.
Oh,
by the way,
I had an epic battle with Yannis Pappas and uh,
Paul Versey got the babe Ruth thing going again.
I know it bugs some of you guys,
but I know a lot of you guys enjoyed it and actually trying to beat those guys.
I mean it was a fucking two one one.
So I was taking my hits like to think I was dishing them out to um,
oh by the way,
Paul version of the verse,
he affects sat down with Yannis Pappas and they allegedly destroyed me on the
babe Ruth debate here.
Here's some interesting stats outside of Babe Ruth
to tell you why I feel like it was an inferior leak.
All right.
Ted Williams was the last guy to ever hit 400 he did it in 1941 nobody has done
it since.
So that's 70 coming on 70 74 seasons going on 75 years.
Nobody has hit 400 yet prior to the 1942 baseball season.
Okay.
Hitting 400 had been done 28 times in a little over 60 years.
Every guy who did it was white and did it in an all white league.
Okay.
And after 1941 it was never done again.
Prior to 1941 they average somebody doing it almost every two years.
Two to two and a half years.
Two to three years.
Somebody hit 400 Honus,
Wagner,
ty Cobb and some Guy Ed Mcdermott or some shit.
You know what they have in common?
All three of them.
Not only did they hit 400,
they did it three fucking times.
Okay?
And this is what funny,
I brought that up to Yannis and I go to,
there was a guy in the 1817 or 1880s hit four 34 for the season and he goes,
oh,
that's ridiculous.
And it is ridiculous compared to 1925 hitting four 34 and 1875 is ridiculous,
but 19 to 1925 as compared to 1965 to me is also ridiculous.
What'd you have during the all white error?
Okay.
What you have is you have not only with Babe Ruth,
you have straight across the board,
unprecedented offensive numbers pick off by the Patriots.
Whoa.
Um,
do you know when the 1930s I did a quick quick research.
I might be wrong for all you baseball heads out there every year in the 1930s
except one year two when the RBI crown,
you had to hit at least 170 rbis.
Honus Wagner,
he hit 100 and 920,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
uh,
Hank Greenberg,
Hank Greenberg had 191 fucking rbis.
Okay.
And what you noticed with all of these crazy fucking stats guys having 30 wins,
seasons,
guys pitching double headers,
guys win and 500 fucking games,
all of that shit.
What you notice is this is ridiculous level of fucking stats.
And then when the game becomes integrated,
all of a sudden those,
those numbers go down and they level the fuck off.
All right?
And I really feel stats from the fifties,
sixties,
70s touchdown patriots,
Lou Garrett Blunt.
We're going to the super bowl into the 80s,
um,
into the 80s.
Like those are left leveled off fucking numbers in some of the greatest pitchers
and some of the greatest hitters of all time played from the 50s into the
fucking eighties and none of them came anywhere close to winning,
hitting long ball,
any of that fucking shit other than a Roger Maris who hits 61 home runs.
Okay.
I guess some,
I think mantle hit like 57 home runs or whatever.
But I'm saying,
and then all of a sudden you had a game that was just steeped in its past and
all the great records and all the shit.
We're all held by these fucking guys whose baseball cars were inside a cigar
boxes.
All right?
And then you notice all of a sudden those records stuck getting broken again.
They live in up the ball.
They made the stadium smaller,
they livened up the ball,
they made the stadium smaller and guys started doing steroids and still the most
fucking rbis anybody ever hit was Manny Ramirez one 65 Sammy Sosa got one 60
both of those guys were on roids and even they couldn't get 170 180 forget about
191 nobody's hitting 400 I'm telling you.
And you're also talking about like all the pitches back then,
the curve ball,
the slider,
split finger fastball,
cut fastball.
All of those pitches were being developed.
So you had a guy like babe Ruth who had an any era monster talent showing up
day.
Yeah,
that guy's going to do some fucking damage and he's going to put up
unprecedented fucking numbers for these guys to sit there.
And since you'd suggest that in 2014 15 if this guy fucking played that,
not only would he hit his hundred something home
runs,
he would also be a cy young award winning pitcher.
It doesn't even fucking make sense.
Okay.
That a guy that talented could fucking exist and then never is there another guy
that talented again.
And despite everything that you saw in a May,
incredible athletes like Bo Jackson do nothing Bo Jackson did as far as
statistics go despite the fact,
okay.
That he was,
that he was arguably definitely gonna be a hall of Famer in baseball and
arguably had the talent to be a hall of Famer in baseball.
The fact that even what he did in his short time paled in comparison to what
Fuck Bay rooted Babe Ruth played in an all fucking white league.
And some of you guys will argue while there was only 10 12 teams and it's like,
fine,
okay,
let's take today's baseball in whittle it all the way down to 12 teams with
those 12 teams,
then go back to being only white guys.
They wouldn't,
they would still be the best of the best.
Okay.
Which when it's all legal and fair,
seems to be predominantly Latino in that sport.
So those people would not be allowed to play.
And right there it becomes inferior.
So I feel like I'm still given Babe Ruth.
Okay.
600 plus home runs for his career.
All right,
but he would have had to have decided to either be a great pitcher or a great
hitter.
That's how it would have fucking gone down.
All right and
okay,
that's it.
I'm not going to debate this any fucking more.
I really feel that Babe Ruth played essentially you had an any era hall of fame
dominant fucking player that played against Division One college talent and I
think that is a fact and I don't give a fuck what you say.
I think because everybody loves baseball.
They are just so steeped in that history that is absolutely sack religious
to talk about these fucking guys in the records that they had in their 500
fucking wins and all of this shit.
I'm telling you man,
come on at the beginning.
I maintain it.
Watching Colby score 80 something points in the two thousands is more.
I think that's more difficult to fucking do then to score a hundred points like
wilt Chamberlain in the 1960 [inaudible].
That's just how I feel.
Okay.
You know,
you got a hundred fucking years of,
this is what I did.
Defense wins championships.
So if you're going to be successful,
they figured they would pitch around Babe Ruth.
They would figure out how they would figure out how to neutralize,
okay,
his talents.
Okay.
Do paypal's went up.
We was hitting against fucking an all white league.
He went up against a guy who sold shoes in the fucking off season.
Like these guys didn't even make enough fucking money.
I mean,
if you babe Ruth,
you did.
But this guy that,
the level of talent he was playing against was so piss poor.
This guy could out and booze.
Any cakes in hot dogs,
not even work out.
You know?
Look,
I'm not saying the guy was,
was,
wasn't one of the greatest of all time.
But you know,
when John Goodman get selected to play you in the fucking movie a life for me,
give me a fucking break.
All right,
I'm done.
That's it.
That's the podcasts.
Go Fuck yourself off all you drum heads out there are fans of Stevie Ray Vaughan
is music or just fans of Chris Leighton's.
Unbelievable drumming.
If you want to listen to have an extra podcast this week,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.